Last time of a about try fennel methyl.
So I thought you might like to see the,
um,
see a space filling model of triathlon
on methyl and feel it how it works.
Remember it was very difficult to find
a way of making Tetra fennel methane,
right?
Which means you have to take this fennel
with its little hook there and get it
into their right.
So I'll pass this around and you can
try twisting it and see if you can make
Tetra federal methane better than
the people before Gomberg did. Okay.
And then there's the question of whether
you can make hex of fennel ethane.
So here are two triathlon on methyls.
One has the hook in it and one doesn't.
So the question is, can you put
those two together? Okay. So Debbie,
you're the first.
So whoever gets it should bring
it up and show it to us. Okay.
The projector is warming up here.
Uh,
so, uh, we're speaking about
tryfan methyl and then,
uh,
I have a little,
a second thought about Friedel crafts
reactions that I'll give to you.
And then we're going to go onto the
next subject, which is carbon compounds.
Once I get once the uh,
senator projector gets warmed up here.
Yeah,
I want to go. Okay, so we talked
last time about how a Steri Kendra,
how are you doing? Is Your
steric hindrance? Sarah?
Debbie. Pretty poorly. Okay.
It's really tough to get these things
together when you have these three
propellers that all have to twist because
of the way they run into one another.
And I still don't have my projector.
I don't know how it got turned off.
I guess I did it somehow. So it
makes, as Debbie's finding out,
it makes Tetra Federal Efa. And did
you try Hex, the fennel ethane? What?
That's even worse. It's even
worse. Okay. So let us see.
I don't know how long it
looks like it's on up there.
How are you guys doing Helen?
Antonio, can you get them together?
Maybe you could get a picture of that.
I'm trying to hold it up so
that he can get a picture there.
Just just turn it between you
work on it as you're doing it.
Yeah.
Don't hold your hand in
the way of the camera.
Yes.
Part quiet a minute.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's true that the models have fixed
angles and don't distort easily these
bottles. If you made it with fishers
models, the ones that had rubber tubing,
you'd have no problem making it cause
they're not space filling either.
And there's the question
of how big the atoms are.
They're a little bit crushable,
right.
These models obviously are
more or less rigid. Right.
And in fact you can make
Tetra fennel methane,
but as we'll see shortly once we
get the projector going for us,
you can't make hex a fennel ethane.
Any luck.
I don't know why this is taking so long.
I turned off the side one and
somehow the center one went off to,
yeah,
I want to turn on one of the
other projectors just in case.
Yeah,
this one doesn't come on. In fact,
I'll turn them all along this.
See where,
where are we getting any luck?
Ah, there we go. Okay, so here
you'll see what we were just saying.
Steric hindrance and
try ethyl methyl causes,
twists that reduce overlap by 25% from
the what they would be a dye fennel
methyl and makes Tetra fennel
very difficult to prepare,
not to mention hexa
fennel ethane. Okay. So,
but Guttenberg was able to make tetra
fennel methane using this trick that he'd
learned in Munich of knocking nitrogen
out and having the two radicals come
together.
And He tried,
as we've mentioned last time to
prove that that's what he had.
The analysis was correct. He
was good at analysis, remember?
And he got the right molecular
weight almost. So then he went back,
he spent just one year in Germany,
not like a free del who spent four
years first and then 17 years in Paris.
Okay. Uh, then he went back to
Ann Arbor and got back to work,
stayed there the rest of his life and he
confirmed the molecular weight by doing
an even better measurement.
He got three 18 versus three 20.
So he was really confident
he had tetra federal methane.
But there was one thing that was funny.
He'd nitrated it did uh,
uh,
aromatic electrophilic
aromatic substitution on the
four phenols got the Tetra
nitrile compound and he got to the
99 and a half percent yield. Okay.
But there was a problem he wrote,
unlike try Nitro,
try fennel methane,
it does dissolve
in sodium athelete that's f
oxide and iron strong base,
nor does it give any coloration.
So his tapped.
So these nitrile compounds with a lot
of federal seem to dissolve and strong
base and to give colors.
Right. But his compound didn't.
Now why does this the
dissolve in strong base?
Any ideas?
What does base do with it?
Strong base
tech.
Yeah.
It takes off h plus.
This is a very good and on it's
triply been Philly plus it. What?
Electron withdrawing nitrile group.
So it's easy to pull off the Proton and
get the an eye on which then dissolves.
And this colored,
he has an unusually high
bone and Mo Lumo nearby,
so it'll absorb like drugs, move,
absorbing light to the colored region.
Okay. So it was possible to get that.
Of course he didn't know this theory.
We know.
So for him it was just funny that it does
all been based the way others NightPro
phenol compounds.
But he wondered how about Pexa
fennel ethic. If you're nitrate,
if will it be color? Well
lit. It was all good things.
So he set about trying to make
mental effort. Now how did he try?
He tried using the technique but
fail to make Tetra fennel method.
It's very much like boards
public, right? You put a metal in,
pull out two chlorides.
The things come together as the idea here.
It's plausible because it's easy to pull
that chloride off as we'll see later.
Okay, so in fact he did get, he
thought perhaps a federal ethic.
Okay, so we did analysis, so we got this,
the total of carbon plus hydrogen that
is co two and water that he burned it in
got was 93.97 by one method.
This is a method,
not a run. He did many, many
analyses using the same method.
Their average was 93.97
he tried another method.
94.2 94.0 94.574 different methods,
a lot, maybe 20 an hour, right?
But he could never get it near 100%
and he was confident that visibility as
an analytical chemist over all that time
you spend in lab,
ultimately he used more than 17 different
methods to analyze it and none of them
would give 100%.
So we concluded that there's something
else there besides carbon and hydrogen
and that something else is oxygen.
Because if you have two oxygens
between the tribe dental methyl groups,
then the sub
them, the psalm of uh, Cnh is 90
pride will come away to give the trifocal
methyl cad I n and then o two minus,
we'll go between so you can get
the, the uh, authentic peroxide, uh,
and it was the same compound. So then
he knew how to prepare the hydrocarbon.
You do it by preparing it
without oxygen present.
It reacts to easily with oxygen.
So we used a special apparatus,
he said with ground glass joints.
Then they used corks and
sometimes rubber stoppers,
but never ground or rarely ground
glass joint. That was really high tech.
But he did it and he got the
compound that analyzed correctly.
But he found it was very funny because
this substance not only reacted with ode
to it reacted easily
with cl two with br too.
And even with I two which you
remember doesn't add to alkenes.
So this is us of weird
unsaturated compounds.
So one saturated react spontaneously
even with I two and certainly Hex,
a fennel ethane shouldn't do that.
Tetra fennel,
methane didn't do anything like that.
So this is the,
this is from his paper in 1900,
just at the turn of the century.
He said,
try fennel methyl.
The experimental evidence presented
above forces me to the conclusion that we
have to deal here with the free radical.
Remember where radicals came from.
Remember it was the nomenclature
in the 1830s and the organic, uh,
radical. And at first they
thought they were real things.
Colby thought he had made methyl,
but in fact he had made the dimer ethane.
Right. And then from then
on, radical was just a name.
It wasn't something that was real.
It wasn't the organic element right here.
He tried to make the
dimer hexa fennel ethane,
but concluded that he had the monomer
try fennel, methyl free radicals, right?
Not just names. Okay. On this assumption
alone to the results described above,
become intelligible and receive
an adequate explanation.
The action of zinc
results as it seems to me,
in the mere abstraction of the halogen
leaving the free radical, the radical,
so formed as apparently stable for it
can be kept both in solution and in the
dry crystal state for weeks.
So he had prepared a free radical.
Now of course,
when you do a reaction you can do,
you either have to go association,
dissociation or dissociation
and association.
And when you dissociate from carbon,
you get something that's try Vaillant.
And this was the first
example of, uh, of, uh,
authentic try Vaillant carbon compound.
So this was,
this is the, the, the, uh, the, uh,
watershed between the 19th century when
it was just making compounds and things
being mysterious.
And the 20th century when you can begin
to understand mechanisms in terms of
actually knowing something about
these try Vaillant carbon compounds.
And this was the first,
okay,
so this launched the American century
of chemistry because this experiment was
done in America, in Ann Arbor, right.
And here in October, 1900, he wrote
the paper and published it in America,
received October 4th and instance of
try Vaillant carbon, try fennel methyl,
but at the same time he
published it in Germany,
a preliminary paper try
federal methyl a case of uh,
try Vaillant carbon received
the 1st of October, 1900.
So he published at both
places to cover his bases.
Now you remember we talked
about the, uh, about, uh,
American organic chemistry and about
James Mason crafts and that essentially
everything he did,
he did in Paris.
And people thought many people
thought he was French, right?
He did essentially nothing in
the u s and that was not, he was,
maybe there were people doing more than
that, but not a lot more than that.
All the center of gravity was in Europe,
especially in Germany. At the end of the,
of the, uh, 19th century.
But Gomberg comes along,
born 25 years later, right. And, Oh,
I should have said that there's
an exception, which is Yale,
because Gibbs really made it complete
international splash with his equilibrium
of heterogeneous substances,
which was published the same period
as the Friedel crafts reaction.
But that was in France and this was
in America. So in physical chemistry,
America had done something and it
was Gibbs, but in organic chemistry,
Gomberg was the first one to really
do something and these are gone Berg's
publications and contrast
that with the previous one.
So here,
uh,
he went for just one year
to Munich and Heidelberg,
where he did this work and prepared
this compound, the Tetra fennel methane,
which was itself notable,
but much more drastic,
was the preparation of the radical
tryfan all methyl, which he did after.
He obviously,
after he got back to America,
so he published these things in German
because that's where the big readership
was.
But within 10 years or so,
he was doing all his publishing in the
United States and a lot of publishing.
So in that 25 year period
between Friedl on Gomberg,
things started really
happening in this country.
And then after the Second World War,
of course Europe had such difficulty that
things really took off here and it was
a long time for them to catch up again.
So this launched the American chemical
century and incidentally one other thing
about it is the big German journal for
organic chemistry was erected there,
Deutsche and Cayman Gazelle shop,
the reports of the, of the uh,
German chemical society.
And in 1900 there were 4,290 pages and
I leaf through them to see how many
graphs there were, how many quantitative
things were being discussed.
This was mainly a journal of organic
chemistry. And there were very,
very few graphs. In fact, in a sense,
two of the papers from this period here,
he gone Berg's papers had more
graphs than all those things in,
in all of 1900 and the
German main literature.
So it showed not only was thing where
things coming to America, but physical,
organic chemistry or the quantitative
approach to organic chemistry was rising
as well.
Now,
I said I had second thoughts
on the Friedel crafts reaction,
what I told you last time.
So I'm going to take just a
minute to tell you about those.
So we talked about rearrangement happening
and Friedel Crafts alkylation uh,
and the idea that that you have, uh,
the, that the, that you can get the, uh,
uh, chloride being complex with
try fennel methyl chloride,
which makes it a good leaving group,
which means that you can,
that the fennel can come
in and displace that.
It's essentially an sn one reaction.
Here's the sub strait with it's good
leaving group and the high home, Oh,
here comes in and displaces,
and then you lose a hydrogen from
the same place and get the product.
You get the normal appropriate
product, the first one there. Okay.
But if it dissociates a little bit
and rearranges with a hydride shift,
right, then you get the other product.
We talked, this is what we talked about.
Okay.
So we said that this is what
gives the primary product.
It's essentially an sn one reaction.
But this sn two reaction
after rearrangement,
when you get the more
stable secondary, uh, cat,
and then it can dissociate and
then you get the, uh, the, uh,
so-called Q mean I Sunpro benzene.
Now that may be true,
but it may be wrong too. I've
got thinking about this. Okay,
so suppose it rotated,
right?
So that methyl was on the backside.
Then what might you expect to happen?
Yeah,
what happened over here to
get the secondary cad iron.
It was a hydride shift,
right? What might you get now?
A method shift and methods and hydride
rearrange it about with about the same
rate. So why not do this?
Right? So why not do meth?
I'd shifts. So what do you get
if you do a myth? I'd shift.
You get that,
but it's the same thing you had before.
It's a degenerate rearrangement.
It's still the primary compound.
And then you could, uh,
you could do the sn one
and get the product.
So that doesn't make any difference
that you do have math. I'd shift,
but suppose the Meth I'd shift
gets stuck halfway across.
Okay.
Suppose it stops there.
Right?
Because another way to draw that
is as protonated cyclo propane,
right? It's Cyclo propane that's
taken on a pro extra proton, right?
And that substance has been studied,
right?
And it's known that it's stability is
between the primary cad ion and the
secondary cad. I am. Right.
So suppose you got that,
what would that do? Well, uh,
if you could have a nucleophile
attack that, I mean,
the methyl plus is a great leaving
group, right? So you could do that.
And again,
it would still give that same product
if you had the protonated Cyclo probate
instead of this thing doing the
alkylation. Okay. Now in fact,
Norman Dino at Penn State University
in 1968, unbeknownst to me,
had actually done that reaction.
He's took benzene and Cyclo propane
and reacted it with acid and got these
products
right.
Okay.
And he used deuterated deuterium here.
So there's deuterium in the, in
the, in this normal propyl benzene,
just one deuterium.
Now what I want you to tell me
is where you expect it to be
on which carbon should that do teary of B?
Which of the three carbons,
let's suppose that it happens by
making protonated Cyclo. Propay. Chris,
what do you say? It should be the
terminal one. Cause if you put it on here,
then you displaced.
That'll be the methyl group and the
deuterium should be there. One Deuterium,
right? Here's what he found. Where is it?
Yeah.
Three sevenths of it is where Chris said
two sevens here and two sevens here.
It's completely scrambled, right? There
are three mouths, three hydrogens here,
two here and two here.
And that one,
deuterium is completely scrambled
among those positions, right?
How did it get scrambled?
Well this corner protonated cyclo propane,
very easily reorder, arranges to
edge protonated, cyclo propane,
and then that can become
protonated at this corner.
And then this edge and then this corner,
and then this edge,
and then back to where you started.
And it does when it's that ch three,
it doesn't have to be the
deuterium you added that moves.
It could've been the hydrogen.
So everything gets scrambled very
quickly going around there. And in fact,
this was shown in a key experiment
by a man named Richard Baird,
who was a assistant professor here in
this department in 1964 and that was on
the basis of that, that Dino tried
this experiment. So that explains it.
So it's pro, so proteinated cyclo
propane does give this compound.
So now we have a question.
Which of these is the thing that
gives the Friedel crafts product?
Is it an sn one sn.
Two reaction with this or
an sn one reaction that
involves the protonated cyclo
propane. And it could be either
right. And no one knows. As far as I
am aware,
right.
I've just been,
we'll do it going through the
literature in the last two days on this,
I don't think anybody knows this.
I tried to call professor Ola and wasn't
able to get him at the University of
southern California who got the Nobel
Prize for free to all crafts things that I
haven't been able to get him yet.
But Professor Saunders who knows a lot
about this, doesn't think he knows.
We'll see. Uh, but any,
I think it's not known.
So what I want you guys to do is
to try to think up an experiment
that can tell you whether it's the
sn two or the sn one mechanism.
Bye.
And I'll give you a hint. I think the
good experiments involve isotopes, right?
So here's a problem for you.
So maybe you can become famous and
know and determine the mechanism of the
Friedel crafts reaction after 143 years.
Oh, okay. Now onto the next subject,
which is carbon eel compounds.
Now, uh, I didn't bring the
texts, the, uh, the, uh, uh,
Joan's textbook along,
but the carbonyl compounds are
discussed in chapter 16 to 19,
which is 268 pages. It's about a
quarter of the textbook, I think.
And that's not a typical, you have
many other texts and you can check,
but there's a lot of stuff in there
about carbon eel compounds. Uh,
the good news is that almost all of it
is review because we've talked a lot
about the reactivity of carbonyl
compounds. So chapter 16,
for example, is aldehydes and ketones.
So for the rest of this lecture,
I'm just going to go over
the big view of this.
And then in the next lecture is we'll,
we'll take a more detailed
view of some of the lore. Okay.
So we talked about before that
the carbonyl compound is stable,
but it's reactive. Those things
we've said before seem contradictory.
It's that the,
you have the average bond energies we've
looked out before for the single and
double bond and for the single
and double bonds to oxygen.
And we've seen that the second bond in
carbon is very much weaker than the first
bond.
But the second bond for oxygen
is stronger than the first bond,
right? And it's not all due
to the, to the Pi bond there,
because the, it has also to do with the
change at hybridization of the carbon.
The sigma bond changes when
you form a double bond.
So it's very stable compared to carbon,
carbon double bonds,
but it's also reactive
because it has a very low, uh,
Lumo the Pi Star. Okay.
Now, just a bit on the,
uh, on, uh, just to give you
something to practice with about Nmr.
To see how people figured out chemical
shifts in an Mr. They did it by taking a
compound, a known compound like
acid aldehyde where n is three here,
you'll see why I use then and
they found it had two peaks,
199.6 and 31.2 right in the CMR spectrum,
carbon magnetic residence.
And then they put another carbon on
and found peaks at those positions.
And then another one on and
found peaks that those positions.
And then they did a ketone acetone,
right. And found peaks at those positions.
And with one more carbon to Buton own,
they found that and with two Penta known,
they found that and
with three penton known,
they found that now with that
empirical evidence behind you,
I want you to figure out what this
is CMR spectrum is of right and,
and which peaks or which,
right.
And that's taken from that chem two 20
problems site that we've mentioned before,
right?
So there's a problem,
there are the values of the chemical
shifts in this proton decoupled CMR
spectrum and use the table to identify
what each of those carbons is.
Okay.
And in the process you'll figure out a
what regularities there are within this
table and how you go about
figuring out new things. Okay.
And just to give you an extra hint,
here's the Proton magnetic resonance
spectrum of the same compound.
Notice this is 400 megahertz for protons.
It was a 100 megahertz for carbon.
That's the same magnet because the
Proton is four times as strong as carbon.
Okay?
And just to help you out with this,
we can blow up each of those peaks and
see what the spin spin splitting is.
And there they are with the
values of their chemical shifts.
And here's the scale in the for
the detail. That's 20 hertz.
And so this splitting here is 1.8 hertz
and the one over here is 6.8 hertz just
for reference. So there's a problem.
There are two problems for you, right?
Make your name by determining the Meccan
devise and experiment to prove the
mechanism of the free del crafts reaction
and figuring out what this compound is.
Okay. Now, so carbon eel is very stable,
but it's also paradoxically reactive.
And we know that's because of Pi Star
for it. We'll see other ways as well.
So the nucleophile comes in,
we've done this a zillion times and
we have nuclear Philly condition.
And last semester we talked about the
Borghi done its angle and all of this is
discussed in chapter 16 and you remember
this contrasts with c double bond.
See where the addition reactions are.
Electrophilic not nuclear filling.
Okay.
So then you bring a proton on
and you get an alcohol, right?
And especially interesting alcohols
that be discussed in chapter 16 are ones
where you form a new bond to our,
where the nucleophile nuclear files
an Al Kill Group, for example,
methyl lithium as that property.
And we talked about that
some last semester or where
the nucleophile is h minus
as in lithium aluminum hydride. So here
are some sections that talk about that.
And again,
we'll talk more about this now,
a different kind of reactivity is when
one of the substituents on the carbon eel
is elite, can be a leaving
group in an sn two reaction.
So it's an okay an ion. Okay.
Because when you do that,
there's something else you can do at this
stage. Of course, you can reverse it.
You can bring these electrons into reform,
the double bond and lose
the nucleophile and go back.
But as in sn two reactions,
you can also lose the leaving group
if it's a reasonable and ion, right?
So you can go like this and now what
you've done is not an addition. What's,
what kind of reaction is this instead of
in addition,
what's overall Linda?
It's a substitution instead
of in addition, nuclear
Felix substitution of things
that are called acid derivatives.
These things,
when l is a leaving group,
when that thing is the leaving
group are called acid derivatives.
So it's association dissociation.
It's not like sn two where you go through,
uh,
pentavalent intermediate
pentavalent transition state,
right? This has an actual intermediate,
this has a finite lifetime,
so it's association and then
dissociation as an aromatic substitution.
Remember the elect electrophilic aromatic
substitution goes through a Tetra
Vaillant carbon.
Then the proton gets lost and you
have the electrified left on there.
And that's what's discussed in chapter 18.
But there are other ways to go at it too,
because the oxygen has unshared pairs,
so acids can attack it. So you
have an acid come in, for example,
a proton to protonate
it and get that cat ion.
And then you can have
electrophilic addition, right?
So a nucleophile then can come in in
a second step. In the previous slide,
we had the nucleophile come in first,
right? And then brought a proton in later.
Now we're bringing the Proton in
first on the oxygen and bringing the
nucleophile in later.
So we get compounds that have
o h and a nucleophile on there.
Now what nuclear files can you use?
Notice that this is much easier
than for c double bond. See, uh,
okay. So you can have the
nuclear file can be, Ooh,
in which case this thing over
here is called a hydrate, right?
It's h two o added to the carbon eel.
Right?
And or it's sometimes called a gem dial.
Gem for [inaudible] for Gemini is twins,
right?
So it's twin Oah is on there.
Okay. Or it can be oh are,
and we've already talked about that Hemi
asset towel or on the way to an asset
towel or it could be nitrogen.
And then the,
the equivalent of how many assets towel
for nitrogen is called a carbon ola
mean. And if you then you can unzip this
of course to go back to the carbon deal.
But if you have two groups on there,
you could unzip losing the other
group and keeping the nucleophile.
And then you have a
nucleophile double bond.
That's what the mean is a
carbon nitrogen double bond.
Or you can have a by sulfide
addition product or a CN.
That one's special because you
formed a new carbon carbon bond.
You're always on the lookout for things
that will form new carbon carbon bonds,
not just change the functional group.
So that's called a Cyan. Oh hydrant.
Hey,
so their section 16 six to 1611
or about that in the Jones book,
but it'll be covered in any of the,
all of these things will be covered
in all these textbooks. Okay. Uh,
now the reason, the reason this
was stable, that it was easy.
One reason it was easy to protonate that
was you have this resident structure,
but notice that if you have a proton
here on the carbon adjacent to the carbon
eel, that's the Alpha position.
So if you have an Alpha Proton,
then a nucleophile can act as a base,
right?
So the base can come in and take the
proton. So instead of attacking here,
it can attack here, right?
And generate this double bond.
And you remember what those
things are called? Enols. Right.
Okay.
So that this is an al rearrangement.
The fourth pattern of reactivity is Al
Lily Cree arrangement. Ketone to Ian.
All I, as I, as I've been going
along, I've been numbering
all the different ways.
Carbonells react.
Okay?
So now you could bring,
uh,
a low Lumo in here and have the
electrons and the double bond attack it.
So this is a,
this is a double bond.
So this is like electrophilic
addition to a double bond, right?
Except it's especially good because you
have the unshared pair on the oxygen
that can help out. And make this easy to
do that. So it's better than other, uh,
than other carbon carbon double bonds.
So the Enal is essentially
a carbon nucleophile.
It can attack low lumos especially easy.
Okay,
so you get something like this and
notice that after you lost the Proton,
then what you have,
what you've done is to do a substitution
at the Alpha position and electrophilic
substitution at the Alpha
position of a ketone. So that's,
or an Aldehyde.
So that's another pattern of reactivity.
And that's chapter 19 these
reactions of enols. Okay?
So enols analytes and analization
a little bit from chapter 19 here.
Okay. So here we have this Alpha
hydrogen. We bring the base in.
As we said last time,
this time we're doing it without having
first put something on the Oh right.
And having a double. So
that, so that this is,
so what we've made now is an an on,
it's PKA is 19 pretty acidic.
Well,
what's it normally for for alkanes if
you didn't have the carbon deal there?
Jesus, over the last
little over 50. Right?
So here we've got a 31
powers of 10 advantage.
So the equilibrium constant.
So that's,
that's how easy it is to make
the enal late. The an ion, right?
Once you have the know late with,
uh,
with the double bond here
and a charge on the oxygen,
then you can put the Proton on the
oxygen and you have an ea knoll.
So another number that's interesting is
the equilibrium constant between here
and here, right? So
this is for forming the,
an eye on this is for the alcoholic
rearrangement of the Proton.
So it's five times 10 to the minus ninth.
So it's it,
you're going to have very little
anal compared to the, to the, uh,
to the ketone.
But notice at equilibrium there'll be
in equilibrium with the same man ion,
right? Because if you lose the proton from
here, you get the same ina late and I,
and that you get from
losing the Proton here.
So if this is ever so much more energetic,
higher in energy than this,
then this one is going
to be unusually acidic.
It's going to be easy for
it to lose that Proton. Uh,
since the Ketone is about 11
kilocalories below the eternal,
the PKA of this is about 11,
right?
Very acidic.
Remember,
normal alcohols are like 16 and 17 Pka,
right? So this is a very, is very acidic.
Now let's go to if one is
good, more is better, right?
Put two carbon hills adjacent to
this, these, this Alpha thing.
So now both of them can stabilize it and
now the PKA is nine and the equilibrium
constant is now three. It's better
to have this than to have this,
right?
Whereas here it was a 10 to the
minus eight of this compared to this,
now it's three times as much. This
is this at equilibrium, right?
Notice that suddenly this
would be hydrogen bonded.
And you can imagine that the hydrogen
could shift from here to here,
this double bond to hear this double bond,
to hear the hydrogen could bounce back
between those two things. In fact,
it's even conceivable it
would be halfway in between.
And Professor Vaccaro in this lab is,
is doing a lot of work on that kind
of thing, compounds of that sort.
So here are the ketone is approximately
equal to the eternal because of the help
from conjugation,
right?
And from hydrogen bonding. Okay? Now,
if you have these double bonds in there,
now this compound is favored by a factor
of 10 to the 13th this Enal is 10 to
the 13th favorite at equilibrium
over this. So you got none of this.
It's all here, right?
Why? Because this one is,
so you've gained the air materiality,
that 30 kilocalories per mole that
you didn't have over here. Okay?
So the ketone is now 17
kilocalories above the enal.
Here are the ido was 11
kilocalories above the ketone.
So you have a complete range of,
of a ketone to anal.
The Pka of this thing here is
10 it's the same as this, right?
The anti and is only about 13
kilocalories per mole of a above funnel.
So it's very easy to lose that.
Then funnel,
if you ever get it on your skin,
Burns like fire.
It's just terrible because
as an organic compound,
it dissolves in your lipids and then it's
a strong acid. So if you ever get it,
you'll know. Did you ever get
into nettles? Stinging nettles.
That's funnels for you. Okay. Okay.
And the PKA in this case is
minus three so this is very,
this really easily loses of Proton.
Okay. Now how about reactions
of carboxylic acids?
Okay. What patterns do we,
we we went through was that,
I think it was five patterns of
reactivity of carbon eel groups.
Now we're going to look
at the carboxylic acids,
which are in chapter 17 and see what
patterns of reactivity we're going to
expect. Well first you can get addition
just as if it were a carbonyl group.
So you could imagine doing that kind
of thing. And there we'll see examples,
right? Another possibility is
to do substitution at carbon.
So this is like the Oah was,
became a leaving group somehow,
right? And then Olr came in, so it
was like, just like the ketones.
We said if there was a leaving group here,
here, the leaving group is o h or we,
or we make it into a better leaving
group somehow. Maybe by protonating it,
something like that.
So we can get substitution at carbon,
but there's another possibility
in the acid you could get,
you could start here and you could
do the substitution at oxygen,
get the same product our on our OCO,
right?
You get the same thing, but make this
bond rather than making that bond.
So you can have substitution at Karbon,
you can have substitution that oxygen.
Okay.
And there's another possibility of course
substitution that the Alpha carbon.
So if you have an R,
a chair and Alpha hydrogen,
then as we saw with aldehydes and Ketones,
you can do a substitution there.
And the good news in all this is
almost all of this is review. In fact,
I should have said one thing on the
previous slide that when you have the Oah
and put the are odd making
the [inaudible] bond,
that's an Alpha substitution also,
it's just that it's an oxygen rather than
a carbon that has the Alpha hydrogen,
right?
So you can have that or on the side.
And the good news is very much
of this is review. For example,
if you look at pages seven 85 to seven 87,
section 69 to 1610,
and the Jones' book,
you'll find that it's an old favorite
of ours. So let's just conclude the, uh,
our here by going through that again,
it's the mechanism for acid
catalyzed hydrolysis of asset towel.
We've already done this,
but it doesn't hurt to do it again
and it's this part of the text. Okay?
So we have this asset towel and
the idea is to hydrolyze it,
to go back to an Aldehyde and how do we
do it? Do you remember acid ketalysis?
Where do we start in?
Even at home
was out here where it's an
acid attacks this compound,
h plus [inaudible].
What is it about the oxygen that
makes the h plus want to go there?
Okay,
so for the goal is going to be,
it's two steps.
First we're going to remove
orr and replace it by Oah.
Then we're going to remove the other
Olr and replace it by Oah. Okay?
So the way we do it is with h plus this
Kate tells us and we have the unshared
pair. And we do that and we get here.
This is exactly one we went over before,
but it's the old ones are the best ones,
right?
Okay. What's going to
happen next? Uh, John,
what do you say?
[inaudible] well, the goal is
what are we trying to do in the first
sage?
John [inaudible]
tomorrow.
How are we going to do it?
[inaudible]
leave now,
right?
Remove Lumara wage.
What do we leave behind?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
where do the electrons go? It's
this bond. We're going to break.
Where are the electrons going to go?
Are they going to go on the Oh,
are they going to go on the seat?
[inaudible]
plus it's going to gain full,
full ownership of that pair of electron.
So it becomes r o h neutral. Right?
So what's left behind on the carbon
[inaudible]
right? The electrons went
away. So what do we draw that
[inaudible] och two left.
What do we draw the ch two.
Okay,
so it's going to do
that and we'll get that.
Now this if this word Aro
if it were just h say right,
that would be a crummy reaction,
right? Why does it work here?
What's good about that?
The bacon
middle is able to stabilize
those electrons. So the
thing gets unusually stable,
right? So you have that and
Bingo. Okay, so we've got,
we've got the first aro off.
Now we have to replace it by Oah.
Uh, Cassie, how are we going to do that?
How are we going to put Oh,
H on here after we took our o off
[inaudible] the Oh,
hi.
Sorry.
Uh, okay. So we want it, we
want to put Oah on that carbon.
How do we do it?
[inaudible]
I'm not sure what Pi's star you're
talking about. There's, there's a,
there's a pie here in
this resonance structure.
But the important thing that we have
is a vacant orbit. A lot in carbon,
which what?
Oxygen.
So suppose that attacks the unshared pair
on the alcohol. You form a bond here.
Now you're here,
right?
Let's go backwards.
So we're going to need something else.
Water each.
What would you use?
Water.
Okay.
So if you put water in that Kat Heins
unusually stable as John told us.
So we bring water in.
Now we make that bond and now we have Ooh,
there.
But we also have h is that a problem?
We want o h here, not h two
o no, just loose proton.
All right, so we've done
the, we've accomplished our
first step up here, right?
We have a Hemi asset towel and
we can check that one off. Okay.
Now we have to take the second aro
off and replace it with, with, Ooh,
how are we going to do that?
Nathan
said, tell me what do we eat? What we're
going to do? What's the first step?
Okay, where do we want to put the h plus
here or here? The top one. The top one.
Okay, so we removed the second one, okay.
By bringing h plus in, put it on the top.
Next
lose water
are, but probably lose alcohol, right? Uh,
to get this and now
and water.
No,
we don't need to add water.
If we wanted to put the second
one in true, I misled you, right?
But really where you go is here, right?
So you just lose a proton. Now you,
so you've taken the,
the key towel to a
carbonyl by way of a Hemi,
a towel or a Hemi Ke Tau. Uh, okay.
So the overall transformation then is
water plus asset towel acid catalyzed to
give carbon old plus two Roi ages.
And we wrote at different reward
at this way before. Right.
They come together and,
and pull it apart.
And so the h two o and resolved
all three molecules. Okay.
That's how much we wanted to do today.
We made it,
we made it to the end and we're caught
up actually with where we were last year.